all right we've got some very thick and
meaty
audience questions today some of which
are coming right at me
and i love it let's get to the first one
david aren't you a hypocrite
for criticizing our financial system
and then making money from it investing
in stocks and bonds
and i'm sure paying as little in taxes
as you are legally allowed to
uh no no i am not a hypocrite listen
that this has been explored in so many
different ways
why doesn't bernie just pay more taxes
and send checks to the irs
why does gnome chomsky one of the
greatest critics of some of the
inequalities in our economic system have
a trust or some other mechanism i
believe it is so he can
transfer his mutual funds which include
ownership of oil companies to his
his kids while paying as little tax as
possible or whatever the case may be
we've really got to disaggregate this
stuff and and
think through in a bit more critical way
what we're really asking here
let's take first let's take some
examples first
um if you believe taxes should be higher
why don't you just send
in more money that's not policy okay
that's not policy the the idea
that just the people who believe
taxes should be higher sending in more
money
is how you resolve a problem with
government tax revenue or fairness or
whatever the case may be
is a joke and in fact if everybody
isn't do it doing it there is really no
reason why one person would do it
because it wouldn't make a difference
and this is why a lot of these things
need to be done collectively the groups
that like to say
just leave this stuff to charity we
don't need social safety nets we can
just leave it to charity well
maybe but that's not policy maybe people
are more generous versus less generous
one year to the next
you can't fix problems in society
predictably with that policy so
you know here in massachusetts you have
i think there's this option you have
to pay a higher income tax rate i think
the income tax rate here is 5.05
and you can pay like 5.8 if you want i
always
put no and in fact i actually don't even
think
the state income tax needs to be higher
i think where we need more and higher
tax brackets or federally but
that's a completely different question
along the same lines i am a person that
exists
in society i believe there are many
problems with our economic system but
does that mean that what i need to do is
put my money under a mattress where its
purchasing power is diminished by
inflation every single year
what would that serve other than to
unnecessarily
impoverish myself by keeping money under
a mattress
i believe for example that capital gains
should be taxed at or as ordinary income
does that mean that when i file my taxes
and i only pay
you know 15 on capital gains i'm gonna
say hey you know what
let me just send the irs more money no
that's not policy there is no
hypocrisy as long as you are not
you know advocating for non-violence and
being a violent person right i mean that
we can find these types of hypocrisy
that would be different
but recognizing that we exist in a
certain financial system
we are people we have a desire for
well-being and whatever else and we are
going to
play by the rules that are there while
explaining that at a societal level we
would be better off if the rules were
changed is not hypocritical and again
the example of noam chomsky
having a trust to i forget the exact uh
um response he had when he was called
out on this some reporter said
you know you talk about inheritance
taxes and this and that but
you invest in mutual funds that hold
pieces of oil companies and
also have a trust to give money to your
kids
chomsky's reaction was what i should i
should uh
be a pauper or i don't remember exactly
what the response was but
the point is these are not societal
uh questions that the individual
is making and of course you should live
your values and if you individually say
for me i would rather lose my money
than have a retirement possibility
that includes owning mutual funds then
do it
then go ahead and do it but to say
anybody
who thinks oil companies are bad but
owns mutual funds
is somehow a bad person come on guys
who even has time to go around uh making
those arguments let's just work on
improving the systems we have and fixing
the problems that we have
rather than trying to find these gotcha
questions of people who
you know have been made have made very
clear what their values are and how they
believe society should be organized
i've got something really cool today the
first 500 people who see this video and
go to davidpakman.com
skill will get a premium membership to
skillshare for two months
for free skillshare is the online
learning community offering
thousands of classes on almost anything
you can imagine everything's taught by
experts
the classes get split up into bite-sized
lessons so even if you're really busy
like me
you can fit skillshare into your
schedule there are classes on
drawing painting photography video
editing web design running a small
business
and that's not even scratching the
surface i got some
great ideas from a recent class i took
called youtube success and even though
we've been on youtube for years i still
got
a lot out of it they have classes for
every skill level whether you want to
get better at something you're already
experienced in or you want to explore
something totally new
and like i said the first 500 people who
see this video and go to davidpakman.com
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two months
giving you access to every class
skillshare
offers check it out i put the link right
underneath this video